good evening one school campus is now
switching to distance learning because
of covid thanks for joining us at six
i'm denise valdis and i'm bryan loftis
good evening frank lamping elementary
near eastern and sun ridge heights says
the move and this is important is only
temporary reporter kate houston speaking
to some parents who are worried this is
happening so soon into the school year
[Music]
if you keep seeing these large amount of
numbers quarantined weekly
i do see them just going ahead and
pushing it back to distance learning for
the safety danielle smith has four kids
in the clark county school district she
was recently notified that one of her
two kids at j.e manch elementary came
into contact with a positive kovid 19
case it was very frustrating because
it was very hard to get through to
anyone at the schools first thing in the
morning smith decided to quarantine all
four of her kids even though the school
told her only one would have to we're
putting these kids at risk by doing that
we need a proper protocol for quarantine
for situations like this when there's
multiple kids in the school district in
the same household according to the ccsd
coveted 19 case tracker there have been
just under 300 positive cases this month
14 this week a lot of his parents were
not expecting that to happen because
when school ended
all the cases were declining melissa via
is trying to switch her daughter to
full-time distance learning due to the
rise in cases i just don't think that
this was planned out right i think the
students should be
at home again
safe now as lamping elementary goes
virtual for the next two weeks vaya
expects this to continue across the
district i just think it was too soon
for the kids to go back and i wish now
that i just would sign my dollar up for
online in the beginning because now look
now i'm on the waiting list kate houston
8 news now
and right now the school district
doesn't have a set number of copit 19
cases that would change the educational
model from in-person to distance
learning they say this is going to vary
and they're going to work with the
health district on a school-by-school
basis